from awesome xenograph
I'm from Senegal where you have to fight
if you want to succeed when negotiating
you have to be tough when a foreigner
arrives in Germany they're treated like
an immigrant who can't do much everyone
who comes here and has skills should be
treated with respect
you never know what a person can do they
mentioned a union gig in above the other
state of kannada nisha Amadou Jala
worked hard to get that respect today he
heads DHL x' freight operation on the
road and rail network he's in charge of
15,000 employees around the world and
speaks six languages fluently dalla went
to school in Senegal and studied in
France and the United States this photo
was taken on the day I left Senegal his
family had very little money his
grandparents were cattle farmers and his
father sold shoes
my father always insisted that we had to
be the best in school and at university
you get curious and stuck wondering what
you could achieve somewhere else that's
when it gets hard because you start to
dream good shoes when I think about
answered Timon
step-by-step armitage Allah made those
dreams a reality a lot of people from
Africa with degrees end up driving taxis
because they didn't get an opportunity
or they just accepted it and I couldn't
settle for working as a cab driver now
he travels around the world for his work
he lives in bond with his family that's
also where he has his office at the DHL
freight headquarters we have a picture
of all the Chinese guys Madhu giallo is
constantly confronted with different
cultures and work conditions his
employer DHL logistics has often been
criticized for paying low wages and
demanding long hours from delivery staff
how does he react to that I stay cool
and calm because you know we have a lot
of delivery people that are coming from
abroad in DHL so you have Senegalese
people like me who are driving trucks
and delivering goods and I know how are
the social conditions in other markets
so I've been working in Asia in Africa
and I think that in Germany you know
people like to complain a lot but people
live a pretty good life so that's why
I'm very relaxed effective communication
comes easily to amadou diallo he's not
overly concerned with hierarchy whether
it's with his staff at the office or
visiting colleagues in freight centers
around the world is also ambitious and a
tough negotiator he may already be a
boss but he doesn't show any signs of
resting on his laurels
but giallo does want to use his success
to give something back he's head of an
NGO called am Roth which works in Africa
the organization aims to give Africans
tools of empowerment it is active in the
health sector it's built hospitals in
Tanzania and laid water pipelines in
Kenya when you read about Africa in many
newspapers you only hear about
catastrophe and actually you know Africa
has more opportunities than catastrophes
but you know people tend to talk about
catastrophes more than they tend to tend
to talk about the positive things so
when I go in Africa I see a lot of happy
energized engaged people and the image
that is still in the media is an image
that is completely outdated even though
a German passport might make it easier
to work and travel Amadou Jala wants to
keep his Senegalese citizenship
I've had many opportunities in Germany
but I've also done a lot of work for
Germany I also want to do something for
my own country and I want to go back
down I'm happy there too but it's been
two hours they're ghoulish
you